Okay.
Good morning.
We're back live.
We have a bunch of different things we
could do today.
The key options at the moment.
There's more I can do on the
visualization port.
And
there's also more to do on well, there's
more to do on the meta stuff which we'll
get back to. So that'll be probably
later today. I think what I'm going to
do at the moment is something a little
bit different.
I'm going to try to actually get some
good profiling done.
And the reason for this is
I want Puffer Lib to actually be close
to hardware optimal.
And you can't do that without knowing
what is hardware optimal. So we're going
to just put together a few little
scripts. Eval MFU. Um,
and we'll see whether this seems like
this is an area where we can make some
decent progress. Me switch this over to
stream view.
yeah, this is what I was looking for.
The torch actually has this flop counter
potentially.
Oh. Uh, the one thing we should do
before this is, um,
we should at least go collect our
experiments, right?
Okay,
got Yes.
good for that.
And do we have this done? Yes, we do.
Okay, so
I'm out of um
I am like out of colors, right?
I Why am I using an LM for this? This so
that's like incredibly incredibly stupid
right
Hey, Shift Tree. Uh, something related.
We're going to do I'll go over what I'm
doing today after I uh get the
experiment results from last night and
get a couple new ones launched. The idea
is that we're going to have all these
experimental results, at least our first
pass at them by the time we have, you
know, the visualizer set up and all
that.
That wasn't that hard now, was it?
Oh, there's no way to to format some
strings other than pasting them into an
LLM.
Like,
you know, the thing that bothers me is
that it even occurred to me to like, oh,
I could just paste this into an LLM and
have an LLM do it do that. Isn't that
just like perverse in some way? Like,
oh, we could have the fuzzy incredibly
bloated thing reformat some strings.
Isn't that like just messed up?
Um,
Hello. I looked into the a life thing.
A life thing. Oh, the conference.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. I remember
papers.
Yeah. It takes a lot of time, you know.
It's not going to be an overnight thing.
I can make it a lot faster than if you'd
be doing this completely on your own,
right? Few points in the right direction
go a long way.
That's actually kind of nice, isn't it?
Look at that.
The triple triad uh one right here.
See, it's got like this nice curve to
it.
Uh, why doesn't this get Oh, yeah, cuz
you can't solve triple triad fully,
right? You don't ever get like the
perfect win rate,
but that's like a nice curve. And a lot
of these have this shape. This is good.
I guess snake we could just rerun.
That's easy, right?
But snake kind of got messed up.
Where'd it go?
Here. Where was my uh my term?
Is this it?
What do you think about mathemat
mathematics in particular?
Wait, do you think it will be necessary
to be a match for the competition?
Oh, no. Well, there's like a minimum
barrier, but the minimum barrier is very
low uh with respect to what other people
think. You need to have seen um partial
derivatives, multivariate partial
derivatives. Well, look, I literally
that tells you all you need to know
about my math background. I just said
multivariate partial derivatives.
More coffee. Yes, you need to have seen
uh partial derivatives ideally with
respect to matrices and things which not
any different from normal.
decent bit of linear algebra, but not
really the theoretical tough proofbased
kind. Just like the getting very
comfortable with tensor operations kind
and a few other operations in there.
Little bit of stats is nice. Um, but
that's kind of all I have. Like the way
that I do all of my work is by being
really really good at the engineering
side.
And I'm not even like an amazing
engineer compared to some of the like
low-level systems people who really know
what they're doing. But the thing is
most AI people are such bad engineers
that I kind of just blow them out of the
water in that department. So it doesn't
matter if you know a bunch of math if
you can't implement anything, right?
It's there are a lot of different what
I'm saying is there are a lot of
different ways to have an edge and to be
able to contribute good stuff. You kind
of just need to identify an approach
that like you are uniquely suited to
execute in a way that nobody has been
able to do before.
Do you recommend doing a PhD in RL? I
never recommend people do a PhD unless
they know that they want to do a PhD,
right? I recommend that you do a PhD if
you know that you want to do a PhD.
mathematics,
PhD. No, statistics is overkill. If
you're a maththeavy person and you can
find a way to leverage it, then
absolutely go ahead, right? But it's not
like, oh, that's what you have to do in
order to be good at this stuff, right?
That's one possible way. That's like one
possible approach.
code looks clean.
Some of it at least I would damn well
hope so, right?
Obviously, if you look at my throwaway
stuff, it's not going to be. But the
stuff I actually put effort into should
be just about
like Yeah.
I'm trying to think like what is even a
good example of stuff I've done lately.
There really isn't a ton cuz lately I've
been doing all this science side stuff.
Oh, let's see about PhD genetic
algorithms and evolution.
Why exactly are you focused on this
class?
This is the one that works.
Oh, I see. I I got the discussion wrong.
The RL is the one that works. Genetics
or stuff is cool, but it doesn't really
work at the moment.
Close to this level of clean.
Well, it depends what you're looking at.
If you're looking at like one of the
simpler MS like snake, uh, neural MMO 3,
I could make way better. Now,
the new constellation code will be very
clean when I finish it.
Oh, yeah. This type of thing. Yeah. So,
this is going to be clean, but then this
is not particularly impressive cuz this
is so short. It's very easy to make
stuff this clean. This is like I think
this is literally the first end I did in
pure C.
I know. I have a couple like hacky
prototype M's that where it's kind of a
mess, but most of the time I try to keep
stuff reasonable.
Yeah, of course you can talk to other
viewers. It's a chat. It's for chatting.
or I come streamers find that
disturbing. What? No, that's the point
of a chat is that you can chat.
As long as you're generally discussing
like tech and stuff and I don't have
like a political flame war or some
[ __ ] in my chat, you're good.
streamers do not allow that. What the
heck? Nuts.
systems program. Want to do some cool RL
shed? Absolutely.
Honestly, like
so the quick version if you have that
kind of a background is puffer lib is
what happens when someone with an AI
background figures out that if you write
like basic low-level code that isn't
completely stupid, everything is just
suddenly a thousand times faster.
And now we're kind of just doing that
with everything.
Like you can literally just do low-level
basic low-level gamedev and actually
contribute meaningfully to research. Um,
if you're better, you know, there are
custom things you can do where you can
create all sorts of like game
environments that are specifically
dedicated to helping us determine or to
like understand one specific aspect of
our algorithms.
There's Perf optimization on the whole
freaking thing. A lot to be done. Sele
all of our M's are in uh in C. Honestly,
I'd like more of the library to be in C
if we could, but the the boundary
between Python and C is really annoying
and it's difficult to push stuff across
it because the Python C API is such a
pain.
Excuse me. I'm just joking though.
All right. So, this will go run sweep
over Snake.
This will get us a better uh better
point for Snake.
still find that daunting. Isn't that
like one of those weird
Oh,
[Music]
Yeah, you should kind of just write the
C.
It's not that hard. How can I join the
puffer lip thing? Yeah, all my stuff's
open source. So, for people who are new
here.
Uh, I am
sort of recentish, PhD graduate. I
started Puffer. Puffer is like a private
lab. All our stuff is free. It's open
source on Puffer.ai.
can start the GitHub, help us out. It's
free. We have like 2,000 people total,
usually 300 plus online in the Discord.
This is where all the dev happens. There
are tons of people to help you get
started. Uh I have a number of guides on
my X here.
I have like theory stuff, I have high
level stuff, but then these two guides
are pretty much all my advice, all my
best advice in one place for general
programming in ML if you're very new or
for RL. If you just follow this, you
will learn RL. And this is way, way more
accessible than the other material out
there. It assumes way less math. It
pretty much just assumes that you have a
decent enough programming background
um and like some AI basics.
And it gives you a step by step on how
to get into it and how to contribute to
the project. And then once you kind of
once you're at the point where you can
build some of these environments, like
if you look at these and say, "Oh yeah,
I could do some projects like this,"
right? And maybe if you've done a couple
of them, then that's where you're at the
level where you can actually really
really push the research forward and
start helping us ask new fundamental
questions. And then all the hardware
that's behind me over there, you know,
we give contributors access to hardware
as well once they've done a few things.
You don't even necessarily need to have
your own hardware. Um, yeah, this is a
comprehensive effort to push
reinforcement learning forward. That's
what this is.
I tend to zone out a lot while I'm
working. So, I figured that this would
be a fun way to like get people involved
with Puffer and also keep me focused.
One human civilization have when you
build one and PR it. Welcome, Sebastian.
For some reason, like look, a lot of a
lot of AI background people have
like this barrier, this mental barrier
to low-level systems programming. I know
I was guilty of this as well, but if you
just look at the code,
like it's really not that bad, okay?
Like this is the snake environment.
It's 200 some odd lines of code. And if
you just read through this line by line,
like this is really not much longer than
the code would be in Python.
And the logic is pretty simple. Yeah,
there's a little bit of low-level stuff
that you normally don't think about, but
like you don't have to really perf
optimize because you can just write
loops and the loops are fast. The
rendering is super basic because ray
know
what does exactly puffer need? Go to
insolve environments. So puffer needs a
lot of things. It depends at what level
you're coming in. So for people who just
want to learn some RL and want to
contribute while having fun,
a lot of these game environments end up
being directly beneficial to our
research because we use these to test
our algorithms and sometimes
environments that we don't expect to be
hard end up being harder than we expect
right and then we are able to ask well
why is that difficult for our algorithm
and we have this new test case in a
sense plus we get these cool demos where
we can show off yeah look our algorithm
is learned to do this it actually plays
the game pretty well. Um, and it's not
just games, right? We have stuff with
drones, we have stuff with driving, we
have lots of things. If you have
experience in a specific area of
industry and want to think about like
how do we leverage Hyperf SIM plus RL to
solve problems in specific industries,
that's useful. If you want to get into
the research side, then that's where you
start asking what types of environments
can we design help elicit problems in
our algorithms.
That's like another thing, right?
designing custom environments to help us
advance specific areas of research.
There's the whole research and science
side itself, which is heavy
experimentation, reading through papers,
combining things from different areas of
the literature that requires a little
bit more experience. There's like
performance optimization of our training
and infrastructure. There's general user
experience stuff where it's like, okay,
we have this really, really complicated
thing. How do we just make this easier
and easier and easier for people to use
and get into?
a ton a ton of different areas. This is
really just a comprehensive effort and
we kind of just leave everything open
for people to get involved wherever they
want to.
when RL's being run the entities run
simultaneously. Yeah, you typically have
like 4,000 or 8,000 parallel
environments at a time.
The other fun thing about this is
because our environments are so fast, we
literally train on more data than like
all of LLM pre-training, we can go
through pabytes of data on one server.
That's just how fast SIM is. Like some
of our SIMs can produce 50 gigs of data
a second when multipprocessed.
Yeah, that's because you're not using
like you're not writing simple low-level
code. So, typically we can run on one
CPU core, we can run over a million
steps per second.
What types of problems do you want to
solve? Guess Tetris frozen lake was done
years ago. So, yes and no, Martin. Um,
technically these problem, a lot of
these problems have been solved. uh but
they've been solved in like a way that's
very brittle. They've been solved in a
way that's overly complex and most of
them are solved in a way where they're
spending like days worth of GPU time on
the one individual task. So we have
something that is much simpler, much
more robust, much more general and can
be uh run in seconds to minutes on your
local machine.
So that's just like orders of magnitude
of improvement, right? And what we're
trying to do essentially is to grow this
big library of environments. Ideally,
some of which pose different types of
challenges. It's just not necessarily
clear up front what types of
environments will pose those challenges
unless you're more advanced. Um, and
then we use all these different
environments for benchmarking. So, to
give you an idea of what I'm doing right
now, my latest project is called Puffer
Constellation.
And this here is a summary of I don't
know like 10 20,000 experiments here.
And these are the best runs of 20,000
experiments.
And this is the trade-off between
performance, compute invested, and then
samples. And then we're going to be able
to do all sorts of analysis based on
this to really help us understand how
our methods work, how they don't work,
where they scale, where they don't
scale. And I'm going to be running this
across all the environments that have
been contributed to puffer lib. So this
is like one way that stuff gets
involved. Now we also do more dedicated
stuff, right? Like this grid environment
here. You see that this has like this
nice like curve this shape. The grid is
an environment that I wrote specifically
to test uh exploration. It is a
variablesized maze environment, right?
Where it's like this very self-contained
test of exploration. And then we use
this for a lot of our algorithm
development to test when we make a
change to our algorithm. If it does well
on this new environment, it's usually a
very good sign.
So we need environments that are more
reflective of real world challenges. We
need some environments that are just
plain harder uh better challenges
overall. Um,
we need environments that are like
self-contained microcosms that help us
test stuff like uh in context learning
uh exploration,
you know, potentially diversity of
strategies like diverse strategy space
where there are multiple ways to solve
it. Like there are tons and tons of
these. It just depends how far you want
to get into the literature to understand
these types of things, right? But what I
say is when people are new and just
trying to do something interesting and
learn a little bit about RL, just make
some low-level games. That usually ends
up being helpful. You learn a lot along
the way. It's a very easy way to get
into it. And my guide covers all of
that. And then as you get more advanced,
you sort of start to get into these, you
know, this more dedicated area of
research.
One bin file being executed. That's not
how these work though. Park
only optimizing the M. We are optimizing
the algorithm as well. Puffer has the
highest performance training
implementation. Our training
implementation can run up to 5 million
steps per second on one GPU.
Puffer is end to end. It's the M, it's
the bindings, the multipprocessing, the
training, the neural net. Like the whole
thing is optimized end to end. We have
our own hyperparameter optimization
routines. We've got our own trainer.
We've got our own algorithm. We're not
really using a fully standard algorithm
anymore.
It's everything.
And I have I've written about pretty
much all of it as well if you check some
of the articles.
So somehow this is still So this is
disappointing because essentially this
was supposed to have
I made some fixes to the environment
that was supposed to have prevented it
from running out of memory, but I think
that the machine just ran out of memory.
Oh yeah. And then for the folks that are
new here, while I'm in this place at
least, I have all the uh I have the
servers behind me and then all the gym
equipment behind me. So I train agents
and then I train myself throughout the
day as well. Let me go reboot that
server and get my first set in for
today.
Uh Puffer typically does GPU for
training and then CPU for SIM, though we
could do GPU for SIM. It wouldn't be
that hard. You usually just don't need
to.
No PR for uh a little bit. I'm down uh I
weigh like 20 lbs less than my peak.
Strength's going to take a while to go
back on
this 350 for five maybe 4 in elevated.
I could definitely pull it off the
ground for a few, but I'm taking it
easy. Trying to get back to my old PR
was 4 410 for two, but that was with a
belt as well.
everything in abundu
and run it on whatever Linux I'm running
abuntu
HPC and wrapping stuff into see well
Martin there's a little bit of domain
expertise that goes with it right
because like there are a million ways to
design hyperrl wrong but yeah it's high
performance simulation
um end to end optimization there's some
algorithm research it's just a
comprehensive ensive effort to make
reinforcement learning like broadly
successful
Yeah, we got the
where is it?
MIT does these like funny mugs where
they just write their logo out of
equations from various different areas
of science. Periodic tables in there.
Yeah, puffer PO.
There's some advancements in there. It's
not just PO anymore.
It's got um trajectory segment level
filtering based on advantage function.
It's got a custom advantage function.
It's got a different optimizer. Got
different learning rate scheduling. just
a lot of different things in it that
make it qualitatively very different.
Development for a while was on Windows.
Well, that's just because I was at it
was in California and that desktop just
happens to still have Windows on it,
which is kind of a bad thing because
if the desktop has Windows then like
there's nothing to prevent me from
installing League of Legends and then
less work gets done. The the thing is if
I don't have any machines that uh if I
don't have any machines with Windows, I
can't install League of Legends.
Okay. Okay. Well, this did run, it
seems, and then it crashed later. I
guess we can actually
do this.
Uhhuh. So, mystery solved.
Yeah. And then then the thing about that
is that game just makes me mad. And it
doesn't even make me mad for all the
reasons that people normally get mad. It
just makes me mad because like I feel
like an idiot. I must I'm terrible at
all games. And I feel like an like a
complete idiot for not being able to
figure out, so to speak, a lot of uh
competitive games, but the truth of the
matter is there's nothing to figure out.
It's just I have feet for hands,
but it still annoys the hell out of me.
So, double distraction, you know.
So, the idea here is while I'm here in
the warehouse,
pretty much all I do is I do research
plus the puffer business. Uh, I do
exercise, about 3 hours of exercise a
day, and I listen to audiobooks. That's
all I do. Very focused.
Are you talking about a specific
implementation or the algorithm in
general?
If you're talking about credit
assignment stuff in g like in general, I
have a really good article on X like why
RL failed to bootstrap that talks a lot
about credit assignment.
14 13 years in Korea. B4 to E1.
Dude, at least you started B4. At least
you haven't seen Iron.
I've seen Iron Four, my guy.
Now, my end goal is to uh my end goal is
to revolutionize science,
particularly areas of science that
depend on simulation
uh with cracked out reinforcement
learning.
That is the end goal.
Pretty fun one.
Did not
I see.
That's funny.
I've played a lot of games, though. The
vast majority of my time has been on
MMOs, which funny enough, my PhD was
basically MMOs, but RL. Um, MMOs are the
only genre I have ever been good at,
like top 1%.
Everything else it's like top 1% there
and everything else is like bottom 20
30%.
Okay, so those are these two
environments.
Now we should have
full constellation.
That was a great field for RL though.
Yeah, it's uh
my my uh PhD actually was very inspired
by Runescape, like right down to the
tick system in that game. It's just an
incredibly incredibly well-designed
environment for RL research.
Oh, I missed a message.
Hang on. I missed I missed a few
messages, didn't I?
RS plus gamma
agent is an elevator learn transate
people.
Oh, uh, yeah. So, that's just discounted
returns. So, it's actually kind of funny
that estimate in Q-learning is biased.
So actually you don't want that
estimate. It's actually better to decay
that estimate from multi-step down to
one step or or like few step over the
course of training. Um it's not well
it's not as biased. It's a better
estimate in on policy learning.
My article goes through a lot of this
stuff though. Like my article is exactly
about credit assignment and uh
differences in on and off pol
uh yeah factorio and like engineering
style games have never those have never
caught me. I played a little
satisfactory but it really didn't catch
me because it feels like a job, right?
The thing with MMOs that always caught
me is there's like the long-term what
are you go like what are you planning to
get towards and then there's the short
term of like whatever mood you're in
there is a gameplay loop that you will
enjoy that will feel really good that
creates progress towards that goal. Um
they're just like perfect and for me
like it just they're just like perfect.
The things are heroin, which is why I
cannot install them because science has
to be accomplished.
Yeah, it's basically like it's designer
heroin.
[Music]
Straight up.
All right. What um I meant to be doing
something here. I meant to be figuring
out what other environments
want to have on this.
Actually almost done with a lot of
these.
Yeah.
Can we do our wear?
Probably can do our right.
Yeah. But the difference is that this
one produces awesome science, right?
How much scientifically use useful
insight can RL sims provide given
current compute architecture limits and
what does puffer change for this? So
puffer makes everything about a thousand
times faster. That's not marketing or
exaggeration. And you can go time like
clean RL SP3. See how fast they're
typically doing RL. You time us, it's a
thousand times faster. Um, so the idea
here, right, is like before Puffer, you
had to be Google in order to actually
run a reasonable quantity of experiments
to figure anything out for sure. Now
we're Google or we may as well be,
right? Because we can actually just run
tons of experiments to figure stuff out
quickly. That's what Puffer changes.
There wasn't a comput architecture
limitation. There was just like a shitty
engineering limitation. And that's what
we fixed.
Plus, now I'm doing my own research on
it, right? You can see that some of our
own research come out of that has come
out of that's been pretty good as well.
And now I'm gearing up to do the largest
scientific analysis of RL experiments
out there.
Yeah, it's like bafflingly dumb.
But the thing is this is my edge, right?
Like I came into this field with an
angle that nobody else had come into it
with, right? That was my edge. That's
why puffer exists cuz it was useful.
And where do I buy the shares? Puffer is
a private company. Can't buy shares of a
private company.
There is there are there is a company
technically two companies behind Puffer.
All their stuff is open source. Uh
professionally, we help companies that
are trying to do RL and having a hard
time of it. We either do custom
simulators, we do integrations with our
stuff, we do advice and support, we do
um contracted R&D.
Now, this is how Puffer buys the
servers.
you'd have to start doing like good
professional work with us and then you
could get a slice of equity.
We do actually pull people from the open
source community for professional work,
but the bar is high. You basically have
to be able to do like one of our more
complex sims on the website. Like if you
can do a project of that scale quickly
on your own or almost on your own, then
you're qualified.
Premium gaming chair. Do you see this
thing? This was the hack that I figured
out is that actually the office chairs,
the gaming chairs, they all suck. All
right. What you do is you buy yourself
like an actual recliner chair and it's
way better.
us, Puffer. Spencer's also doing stuff
with us full-time now,
plus the open source community and stuff
around it.
Couple other people I've pulled in for
various things.
You're being for real. I'm going all in.
Go ask around. Pretty much everything's
out there.
The only thing is the bar is high,
right, for the professional side because
Buffer is a small company. This is a new
company, right? This is a new thing. And
most of my time doesn't go into the
business side, right? Most of my time
goes into pushing forward the core
research.
So on that side of things, we really
need people who are going to be able to
like
at least have passively decent
interactions with clients, ideally like
help, you know, scope things, be able to
build custom SIMs, be able to spin up
enough on the RL to identify, you know,
how to do stuff in a way such that you
don't butt up against unsolved problems
or at least know when you're going to
need some experience. But you can get
there and you can get there quite
quickly if you put in the work and you
get a very valuable skill set to boot
Well, the thing is like it'll be
interesting if you show some result,
right? Like most stuff in genetic
algorithms there really have not been. I
haven't seen a ton of promise shown so
far. I actually do think that it's
possible that you could make stuff work,
but you'd have to do it in a way that
has not been done so far. Bootstrap the
business to fund your own research
pretty much. So, not just my own
research, right? The goal is to fund
like a small private lab,
maybe eventually a medium-sized private
lab.
more tooling on top of puffer lab. Well,
this is what I'm doing right now, right?
What's this? Like this is tooling,
right? This is going to be open source
as part of puffer.
This is not like going into a paid
product. This is just going into the
open source.
I buy when I share some results. Yeah,
of course.
Yeah, of course.
I mean, there are a number of ways I
could do this, right?
I'm always upfront with people. So,
Puffer is for profit. It's just not like
maximum. It's not maximum profit, right?
The idea is I'm doing this because I
want to advance this area of science and
I think I can make plenty of money along
the way. I'm not going to not advance
science, you know, and just try to make
more money.
Growth has been very good.
People have been very happy with what
we've delivered so far.
The science is going amazingly well as
well. Like the research side is going
amazingly.
I mean, I've at least like I've had
plenty of investors talk to me, right?
Some good ones as well. But it's like
inevitably most of the investors are
just going to try to tie you down in
ways that conflict with advancing the
science.
I'd rather do things my own way.
Not bought by Nvidia. I actually they're
using um I know at least one group
internally is using Puffer for some
stuff. I'm working on a collaboration
with them as well to see if we can get
like some cool partnerships going.
What am I drinking? This is black
coffee.
This is um seven out of 10 soda. That's
not bad for you. They're called
lollipops.
Okay, so we now have these experiments
going.
That took longer than it should have,
but hey, I was having a chill time
chatting.
Um, and we also got all of this.
Now, we have 10 environments.
So, this is a minimum of 12,000
experiments, though realistically this
is over 20,000 experiments.
Pretty cool.
And now we're going to start on
on this stuff.
So, does this actually exist or is this
um Grock lying to me?
Oh,
apparently
Okay.
So,
let's just build a little profile thing.
And then what we're going to do right
now, I should explain
So, uh, I've been working on yesterday I
was working on the C port of this
experiment stuff. I will be doing more
of this this week, but I did a bunch of
hours of this yesterday and I was
starting to get bored. So, I'm going to
do the other side of this. Um, the goal
of this project, right, is very large
scale experiments,
analysis, and then optimization of
hyperparameters to different compute and
data regimes.
The problem is that puffer is compute
optimized like it is effective when you
run high high data regime. It becomes
less efficient when you run lower data
regime. And I haven't even really tried
to optimize. So what we're going to try
to do is we're going to try to get some
formal calculations of the efficiency of
puffer lib um under different settings
and we're going to see if we can
optimize based on that.
Is there a way to generate games
environments?
Not really. You kind of just have to
write them.
It's like the super trendy things like,
"Oh, maybe we can just autogen these."
But then it just never works,
It's less efficient. It's less hardware
efficient, but like it's fewer the
number of you're not getting anywhere
near the number of flops out of your GPU
that you should be.
That makes sense.
mixing features.
It's very difficult in a way to do that
in a way that actually gives you the
coverage that you want.
world models. Yeah, they're kind of just
crap.
And then the thing is they're also like
orders of magnitude slower.
I'm not even like super sure that that
the approach fundamentally makes sense.
Okay. Uh, this container needs to be
rebooted.
Cool. I will be back in a couple
minutes, few minutes and uh we will
continue on profiling etc.
deadlift's hard. I went from um I was
doing
sets of 335 in California from the
ground and I went to 350
from 4 in. This actually should be
easier. It's just going to take me a
week to get back into the swing of it.
I think one more set of those today.
Then we have uh
Probably
leg curls, lying leg curls, some
shoulder work.
That
What was I doing with this? Oh, yeah.
The profile, right?
This barely makes a difference. All
right, so
flops.
What on earth is all this crap?
Anything meaningful in this?
All right, just some stream stuff.
Ignore this.
Okay.
So what we do is
You see RL going back to CPU? What do
you mean back to CPU?
Since when was RL on CPU?
It's only the environments that are on
CPU, not training.
GPUs. Well, yeah, but the thing is like
as soon as ML moved to GPU, so did RL
pretty much. Like why on earth would you
ever do RL on CPU? Like the models
like technically yes, you can do it for
some of the really small ones and it's
actually not half bad.
But like
we know that the models for more complex
problems at least get into the tens or
maybe low hundreds of millions. So even
if you expect that a lot of problems are
going to require that much scaling
that's already too big for CPU um to do
efficiently.
If I go up to
this
Got some fatigue on me today. I wonder
why.
missing forward function.
Function.
Okay, better, right? Much better.
Um
yellows
Well, this seems like it's saturating,
right?
If I add in a couple more layers, it
doesn't help.
See if there's like anything I'm
missing.
I've done this before and I've gotten
pretty similar stuff where like you get
only like 50%.
That's no good.
We might have to try compile. We might
have to try other stuff, but we're going
to get this to work.
putting the question first.
I don't have any interest in like
context engineering
LMS. I'm going to put the thing see if I
get anything and if I don't I'll go
figure it out.
I honestly hate using these as much as I
even do.
Uh,
EA's 48.
48.
I guess there are a couple
possibilities, right? Like
it could also be the MFU calc is
Why does nobody do these?
Am I crazy or should there just like
does it seem like they're nowhere near
enough per test
and this is consistent with other stuff
I've seen.
Obsidian notes guy. Nope.
I really don't like a lot of structured
uh structured note stuff.
Okay. So, here's somebody who's done the
same thing.
Let me just try before I before I like
really get into this. Let me see if I
can just look into uh into something,
right?
Um,
that would be wrong, right?
Well, that definitely spun the GPU fans.
Uh
Isn't there like this tensor core
thingy?
Ah,
there we go. Look at that.
That's so annoying though that you
literally uh if you don't set this
thing, it just doesn't give you your
flops. You either set this flag or you
don't get your flops.
This is very close to the peak
FP16.
Okay.
So,
You can't just do
terra ops and not give me.
Does anybody know where the the full
data sheet is for this?
cars today.
But we don't care about that.
Oh, okay. Okay, so this is supposed to
be
Hang on. We're supposed to be able to
get 330 then, right? So, I get 150, but
we're supposed to be able to get 330.
Clarity.
This is not necessarily crucial to be
fair,
but it's possible we uh we can get some
good stuff from this.
I think it would be really cool to get
um
e- flops in the dashboard.
We can see exactly
what efficiency we're running at.
the like shared weights multiple passes
through same net stuff
kind of good for this
I have to just check if that's that's
actually a good question. Is this doing
accumulate somewhere?
Oh, is this um Hang on.
I read this right.
FP16
with FP16. No, I should be able to do
this, right?
Well, this is not supposed to be this
high. It's mostly they get 2x
So, uh,
wait, what does the one that Hang on.
There are two different things going on
here that are weird.
Wait, I'm very confused.
I thought um
Okay.
Interesting.
I was there for shooters. Couldn't break
top. Welcome
Well, I suppose this is irrelevant
because nobody uses this anyways, right?
Wait, then isn't this mean that Bflat
isn't nerfed?
I'm very confused.
I'm going to have to go see if it keeps
doing that.
Let me go figure out why the hell this
thing keeps buzzing obnoxiously loudly.
Okay.
Don't know why my washing machine has
suddenly decided to freaking 10x the
volume
when it announces it's done.
Okay, I just messed it up. That's fine
then.
Oh.
Um, because it's batch.
Is it time second?
It is right.
Oh, you literally have it. None, don't
you?
This is probably the AM screw up if I
think about it. Right.
Like stuff like this.
This is kind of fun for today.
This is enjoyable and probably useful.
If I go down to a more moderate 512
77.
Oh yeah, let's just check real quick.
Uh
yeah. So it's missing the map
somehow.
Oh, I bought
something's wrong with my um
something is wrong with this profile
counter.
Missing Matt Mole somehow.
Yeah.
Why is it not counting map moles?
So weird.
[Music]
That's really obnoxious, isn't it?
Hey, Jess.
What's up with the title?
Oh,
glad you asked. Thank you for the
reminder.
That is what is up with the title. Let
me get more coffee.
Uh,
this is weird.
We'll do it in BF16 for now then since
it actually freaking works.
Um, first of all,
if we can get this to peak,
I want to see if this is actually going
to get near max.
That's actually lower. Interesting.
Okay, so
presumably this is much lower.
28.
like our standard setting.
It's actually not terrible that this
ends up at 68
teraflops.
Of course when you do this
I bet you this is freaking
me
what version do I have in the the docker
I think it's just some weird screwy
thing with compile in this version.
Welcome, Obito.
Yes, you have not shown up for the
morning shift.
That's definitely how it works, right?
All right. What the hell's wrong with
this thing?
Why is
What do I import so that this thing
doesn't just break?
Well, it's just broken out of the box in
this case. It's not even anything I'm
doing. It's just the freaking compile op
just doesn't work. I don't know why.
Oh, you know what? I see it. I'm stupid.
I'm freaking stupid.
I've literally done this before as well
and I still forget
Python so much
there.
Boom.
You can't name something profile.
Literally, that's what it was.
Doesn't that suck?
I also don't see this.
It doesn't seem to be doing anything.
Maybe it's just not
Yeah. So, this stuff is just straight up
not getting applied, right?
Yeah. So, this doesn't tell me anything,
right?
Nothing at all. Lovely.
literally faster without compile on.
This is the thing that I always see is
the compile thing just sucks. Like torch
compile just [ __ ] sucks.
That's the thing that I always see.
It's like I always try to go like, "Oh
yeah, maybe we'll get torch compile."
And it just sucks.
And like I've done this in puffer, I've
done this outside of puffer.
What do I do?
as soon as you turn this thing off.
Better, right?
Consistently.
Let's see. Has anybody ever figured out
why the hell
Do you know how to make Torch Compile
not just be completely worthless?
Because right now, this is probably at
least the fifth time I've played with
torch compile because everyone says it's
so great. And literally every time it's
just completely worthless. literally
makes the model slower.
I think we need ends sight, right? We
actually need to set up like torch
profiling.
and I probably am going to want to run
this locally.
This doesn't depend on
much of anything.
I thought I had something locally on
this
Okay. So, we're going to set up a local
a full local install, I guess.
Yeah, I think we're going to just do
this entire
this entire thing, right?
Try this
and hopefully we're good
and do not break things
and hopefully I especially do not break
my system.
We shall see.
Why not? While I wait for this, why
don't I start on the uh Oops.
Never mind. I suppose I suppose it's
already done.
So, we open this big chunky profiler
thing.
I've not used this before, but I
typically do not like the heavy things,
but it's time to actually profile stuff
correctly.
We might even end up having to deal with
jacks today. Wouldn't that be funny?
I warn you, if we do have to deal with
Jack, it's not going to be um
it's not going to be me being like, "Oh,
look, Jax is so great." It's going to be
me just being mad the whole time.
Huh?
What?
See if I just put this chunk of it over
here. You can still kind of see
everything that matters.
So, how do I see which chunk of this is
my actual runtime?
Okay, so this is the environment right
here. These are some environment calls,
I suppose.
I'm confused as to how
the events should all just be right
here, right?
Yeah, there we go.
I don't know what I'm looking at if
there's nothing here.
Yeah, like this [ __ ] is like I assume
that they just have changed the API a
whole bunch and like
now it's just the old calls just don't
work or something. I don't know.
Why do I not see
I don't see NVX.
I'm uh I'm trying to figure out
I'm working on trying to profile
uh some basic torch stuff. I'm trying to
get a sense of how we optimize small
networks and overhead and the like.
new env.
Yeah.
Um, so basically I'm trying to do a much
deeper uh passive optimization because
now we have
now we're not just in super high data
regime where batches are big. But I'm
trying to do all of
Yeah, I love uh LMS. They're just so
great.
[ __ ] off. Um,
I love that we just outsourced having
documentation of [ __ ] to that.
Can I see the activations at all in
this?
like this.
This not it here.
Looks like this is it, right? This
block.
Yeah, it looks like this is the actual
thing, right?
Yeah. So, this is it. Like everything
else that was all just initialization.
Go here.
I mean, they're just all these like
little tiny
just a ton of these little tiny kernel
calls, right?
But like I don't see what I'm supposed
to do with this knowledge. It's like,
yay, there's some kernels and they're
not spaced correctly. And then the thing
that's supposed to fix this, which is
compile
to generate graphs, doesn't [ __ ]
work.
So this gives us
wait if I do like this
even lives apart from that. Okay. It's
like tiny little net.
I guess you know what I'd like to do?
I have an idea.
cuz this is like this is messed up, you
know.
Okay.
Um, so I mean regardless, like certainly
if this is supposed to be a useful
thing,
it shouldn't just be slower.
3.2.
Yeah, it shouldn't be slower out of the
box like this. Cool.
I'm going to try to get this I'm going
to try to get Grock to put this in
Jacks.
I want to see. I mean the thing is I
expect that this should be slow because
compile doesn't freaking work
using M's template
which are the best to copy from well the
one that's literally called template is
the starting point and um simple
multi-agent snake Simple
single agent end very simple single
agent end is like squared
um
whatchamacall convert is fine uh what's
the other one target is fine neural mmo3
code is a decent like longer end
yeah it's in the docs is in the docks
I'm letting this do this. Uh the goal
here is not that we're going to
necessarily like oh now time to report
to Jax. It's to figure out what the
hell's wrong with torch.
Um
yeah, give me a few minutes folks. I
will be back directly.
Yeah, FBI. I know. I'm just doing
something. Don't worry.
right. So, it's well known that I hate
jacks. What the hell am I doing? Um,
I am just trying to get a comparison
to see if it's the
basically to get an upper bound. I'm
just trying to see how well you can do
with really small nets and if this is
like magically better.
moving.
Well, I don't want to move to Jacks. I
[ __ ] hate Jacks. It's a terrible
library made by people who think that
they're much cleverer than they are.
Maybe not made by people. Maybe the jack
the jacks are probably pretty good. I
think the whole like stuff around it
though has just become completely
stupid.
Like people just write such garbage code
and it's still slow.
Before you had decent code that was
slow. Now you have terrible code that's
slow.
Yeah, pretty much. Like, oh, we need to
react. Oh, yeah. Maybe you're just bad.
You're bad at everything. Go away.
See, this [ __ ] is just like, "Oh, look.
We made it so nice." But you didn't.
It's just like
every single time I go to use it,
there's some versioning [ __ ]
upgrade your CDN.
But then how do we do that?
But this is like KDNN specifically.
Oh, wait. Hang on.
It's like so obnoxious.
They're not even um
none of these are even close. What the
hell?
Well, yeah. And it's just like, oh, we
made it pretty. And it's like, okay, you
made it pretty, but you also It doesn't
[ __ ] work. Like,
every single time I've tried to mess
with it as well, it's something like
this. So, can you blame me for just
saying, "Okay, these devs are dumb." I'm
not going to do that. Thank you.
Oh, lovely. I'm sure this will break
nothing at all.
It's just such a dumb library is what it
is.
What does it do?
It cannot be Well, I mean, if you want
to go implement your own pietor torture
jacks be my guess,
I'm not using it for environments, dude.
I just want to do like run some timings
and I forgot that this entire like
ecosystem is stupid
or at least I forgot it's this stupid
like I don't know how you bork and
install so
in Python was a bottleneck.
Well, sometimes it is. It often is
an actual good language.
Well, because there aren't any actual
good languages for everything really.
At least no popular ones.
It's like C++. You're an idiot. Rust,
you're an idiot. Go close, but you're
still an idiot.
C. Pretty good. Strings are really
painful. Bunch of other things are
really painful. You kind of don't need
that level of per for literally
everything you Oh.
>> Yeah. The problem with all the new
little like the new and trendy little
programming languages is you're
basically just tanking your project by
writing it in that
none of the mainstream popular languages
are like good really
like the least bad thing I found is just
Python on plus C, but it's like
it's still so obnoxious.
I love having this stupid thing just not
Come on.
I don't ever do like this type of crap
where I'm like pasting full chunks into
a language model. It's like, oh, you
know, we solve a competitive
programming, we, you know, the best
model. There will be no more human
programmers and it can't write a 40line
script.
Like, piss off.
Actually, what's going to happen is
after this we're going to have to do um
so if this is better then I'm going to
have to try a bunch of other stuff in in
torch. I think if this is actually
worse, then it's going to be really
funny.
I see. So this is like
just freaking TPUs, right?
Yeah, they charge like $2 a chip. Oh,
wait. This is five.
Oh, that's four B. That's crazy.
4 pod
per chip hour.
Yeah. So that's crazy expensive.
So I think that they're just like
Can I figure out what's going on with
this stupid thing? Even though it's dumb
Jack's code. I don't know what this
lower is.
This lower [ __ ]
Where's this cost analysis?
Did it just make this [ __ ] up?
Well, I mean that's really cool, but
does it work?
So, it's actually this says it's faster
in torch out of the box,
right?
Thank you. unnamed.
I got it though. Think I caught it. Lav
constellation. Oh yeah, that's what
we're going to get back to. So the idea
here to give you a sense of what I'm
doing. This is not just random unrelated
perf optimization.
The idea is that um the higher cost
points that uh constellation is finding
a lot of them are going to be like lower
batch sizes and stuff where they're not
going to use the hardware as
efficiently. So I'm just trying to see
if we can optimize hardware uh more
effectively for smaller networks etc.
So
the outcome of this so far is um
what happens if I do this.
What happens if we just take Jax and we
don't compile?
So Jax, you get the expected speed up
with compile.
It's just that the speed sucks.
we should try to make this more
conclusive.
I actually I sent um some Nvidia folks
an email this morning. One of the things
I'm really hoping is I could get some
Nvidia people who actually know how to
really optimize
really optimize GPU PF
because like the small nets are just
running at
literally 3%
max theoretical throughput.
Okay,
we will try this thing.
So
this is our initial benchmark.
Why would I send Deepseek an email? They
optimize big models.
Oh yeah. So that noise gen is going to
dominate, right?
You see how it's literally already
starting to write garbage? Like, what
the [ __ ] is this?
or eyeloop.
Oh, well, yeah, that's cheating. You
can't compile
the entire training.
Okay, I actually I see.
Uh, so that's going to try to like Yeah,
I see. So you can't compile this or
Okay. So
hang on. I know what we're do.
Oh, I missed uh Nicholas having issues
with DQN. What's a good way to test it?
Some good tests or things to look into?
Yeah, DQN is it's the thing is it's such
a weak algorithm that like I'll tell you
that I did do it recentlyish
with big batches and like good optimizer
and stuff and I was able to get it to do
like carpole you like carpole should be
a consistent enough task.
What's a good test to check the code is
good? That's the problem with these
algorithms, right? The problem with RL
algorithms is the test is whether they
solve, you know, fixed known
environments. That's why it's hard.
It's not like you write a sign function
and you can check the outputs of a sign
function, right?
Worked on voids. Yep. Reward algorithm
got it to train successfully.
Awesome. Got a PR for it. You got some
cool void stuff. We'd be very happy to
see that.
Setting learning dynamics. Not really
whether performance is good.
Grading is correct. Yeah, but that's the
problem. There's not like an easy check
for that.
Low key hustling this.
I mean, this is just me typing [ __ ] into
a stupid LLM. This is like nothing
remotely impressive. This is completely
brain dead.
Man, way to type [ __ ] into that LLM.
Like this is just me like debugging
stuff and like trying to get some quick
benchmarks in an area that like I don't
normally work in.
Well, I mean, I generally I'm actually
while I'm here, I've got a pretty strict
schedule.
It's a pretty funny schedule, actually.
Let me go get my couple sets in and I'll
tell
right.
So, here's the schedule. I wake up at 7,
actually 710 because screw that one
snooze.
I make myself coffee. I go lip that bar
once. Um, I go run a little over 5 and a
half miles,
hour long runish, a hard sort of hard
course.
Then I get back,
get a shower around 9.
Uh, around 9:30, I take care of some
emails and administrative stuff for
Puffer. Get breakfast at 10:00.
Streaming at 10:30. streaming 10:30
until about 6:00 p p.m.
Have dinner at 6.
Back to work at 6:30. I either stream or
I work on client stuff in the evening
off stream. Um until 9.
Oh yeah. Uh 9 I do an hour of
stretching, working on flexibility
till 10. I go to bed. And then
throughout the day while I'm doing my
stream, I get about an hour worth of
lifting in
the sport. An important counterpart
pretty much. Yeah. It keeps me sane
and keeps me healthy because I'm sitting
in a chair all day otherwise.
I was able to get a job and I'm texting
you at my job. Oh, hey man. Awesome.
Congrats.
Pretty much same exact speed as before.
Mr. No name.
axe. Oh yeah, that's a decent thing.
Hang on.
I do remember that as being better
sometimes. Oops.
Max auto tone. No
graphs.
Still lower than uh
I just do with the Let's Let's see if
this is even better.
It's really obnoxious though, the
startup on this. Oh, and it sucks.
Yep, that sucks. Uh,
pending uninvoke backwards.
Oh, that's interesting.
max.
Yeah.
So, it was actually um we'll have to see
how the compile modes affect this
afterwards, but it was the fact that it
was storing gradients.
We also want to get rid of this like RNG
[ __ ] if we can.
Okay, so
here's the torch one.
so Jax without compile sucks, right?
Like all the damn perf comes from
from it.
PyTorch likes its compile too.
It generally seems better without
messing without it though like
So basically this just means um
we want to compile
like the entire training loop if we can,
right?
Let's see if the uh the mode changes
anything.
does
actually do need max autotune
I would like to get rid of this noise
calc.
Oh, and uh we also didn't try.
What just happens if I do this?
In torch version, compile the model 2.
What do you mean in torch version?
Isn't this it?
Oh, you're saying, do I need to compile
this separately? Is that what you're
saying?
Pretty decent terops, actually. The
whole lake.
Yeah, that doesn't do anything. It's
already compiling the full model when I
do it this way.
I mean this is like massively
like the fact that this
literally just like this super simple
model
equals I did that right I just did
model equals I did that right I just did that and it doesn't I think you're
that and it doesn't I think you're
behind a minute on this Okay. Cuz like
it I did that and it didn't make a
difference.
Okay, this doesn't change it. This is
nice.
Wait, wait, wait. I thought I did that,
didn't I? If I just do here, right?
Model equals
I think it's the same, man.
I'm pretty sure it's getting compiled,
right?
Okay, this this is way better, right?
All right, so we weren't we didn't have
a good enough warm up here. Now, let's
see. 10.79.
Yeah, that compile doesn't do anything,
man.
So
that's kind of interesting, isn't it?
We are able to get up to 10
10 teraflops on really small nets.
I think that we can actually make puffer
like way faster on some of the really
small models.
Yeah, there's so much to be done here.
My gosh,
But at least like
I think that this tells me at the very
least that
So we can just go based on the compile,
right?
Okay, there's like at least a 4x speed
up to be gained here.
yeah, I mean this like actually it's
like an 8x speed up, isn't it? Because
this is also BF16.
Yeah. So, we can just make Puffer like
stupid fast.
Actually, can't we just figure this out
right now?
Oh, cuz it can't be n
to be n, right?
million.
Um,
that'd be kind of nuts, wouldn't it?
Say there's like overhead. Yeah, that's
still crazy.
Okay. Well,
I mean, there's going to be the LSTM and
everything involved, but like
puffer can be way faster.
Uh we just did a bunch of profiling is
all FBR. We did some profiling seeing
like okay what happens if you really try
to optimize small networks and this is
what's happened
what I'm going to do now is I'm going to
go do a couple sets
I'm going to switch over and probably
work on the meta stuff for a bit
and then we'll see what I do with this.
But like this is the other side of what
I wanted to do with puffer.
And I think that this is like a this is
a very very strong and encouraging
result at the very least.
Probably what I'm going to do based on
this right
network size is tiny FBR. It's just like
16 to 128 to 16.
But like the idea here is um
previously puffer was optimized for
small nets with big data batches. Now
we're also having it optimized for small
batches.
And I think that this max autotune
actually can get cached as well, right?
protein suggest is pretty slow.
Yeah, that's kind of this uh annoying
bit about the Gaussian processes.
There are ways to mitigate it, but
you're right. I need to fix that as
well. I mean, that'll be this will all
be I think part of Puffer 4.
I think Puffer 4
I think the science bit is going to be
the really large scale analysis and then
we're just going to like crush speed.
That's going to be pretty good.
There might be some algorithmic stuff as
well, but I think that the priority is
going to be just like
really good science and analysis. Crush
speed.
Run 200 of the sweep.
Uh, yeah. So, that's because there's
also down sample equals 10, I believe.
So, it's 2,000 data points, 2,000
suggestions, and Gaussian processes are
cubic. If I recall,
I've actually like done some small stuff
to mitigate this in this branch, but
it's going to have to be changed
fundamentally. I think the good news is
I have nothing else to do for the most
part for the next quite a bit. like I
have some client work to do, but then
being here at this uh where I am here,
it's like there's basically zero
friction and zero overhead to every
other part of my life. Like I just get a
lot of time back that I don't normally
have.
Suggest does 1,000 train steps inside of
it by default. Oh, well that's bad.
Yeah, I think
this is one of those obnoxious things
because the way to test changes. I think
that what we would do for this is like
let's take let's say that we're going to
take breakout and pong as our test
environments for uh the hyper pram
sweep. And actually, if you would like
to help with this, uh, the way that you
would do it is you would get your
baseline sweep, full sweep of Pong and
of Breakout with the, uh, protein as it
is now. And then you would make your
changes to speed it up. You'd rerun the
sweep and you'd see if you still get the
same uh, like approximate distribution
of points or if it messes it up.
Where will the main speed games uh gains
come from? Missed most of the stream. Uh
you're going to get some from BF-16
and you're going to hopefully you're
going to get some from BF16
and but then mainly you're going to get
some from we're going to have to do
compile basically in a way that I
haven't done before.
The barn it is a warehouse.
We've got warehouse. We've got the gym
equipment.
All right, so here's the here's the
plan. Let me use a restroom real quick.
Let me do a couple of sets. Switch over
to meta
and
I'm going to see if I can get them
something because they are like trying
to get baselines and having a tough time
this evening. I have some client work to
do.
I've got like two-ish hours. I think in
two-ish hours I can hopefully get the
meta stuff in a good enough spot that
tomorrow
tomorrow we can do either full work on
viz or full work on the client or full
work like the uh the new cport of the
client or we can do full work on this
depending on what I'm feeling and it's
only Wednesday and then we'll basically
have in just the first few days I've
been here we'll have set the groundwork
for the whole of what's going to be the
next update which is pretty solid
progress. this.
All right, I'll be right back.
I think I said I should set up the meta
stuff on I have it on a different box,
don't I?
Let me figure out what they've told me
to do.
Let me just go find their thing. Hip
install.
I'm trying to think what's the easiest
way to just like set this thing up on
its own.
What's wrong with this?
Is my internet dead?
Doesn't seem so.
What's wrong with GitHub? Are you
serious?
Oh, lovely.
I go to um
Wait, is it me though? Or
if I go here, does it load?
Yeah, it's just it's GitHub. What the
hell?
Yeah. Yeah. It was just some weird
thing. I don't know.
Good now. Hey, Kvert.
No attribute get game. Lovely. They
changed it again.
That's
It's Okay.
Well, I'm just going to go insane with
this.
I'm just going to go completely insane.
It's like every single time I pull
something, there's like new [ __ ]
wrong.
It's like I want to help these guys.
It's just they don't make it very easy
for me to help them when things are like
things are like this.
Like it no longer creates the same
thing.
Okay. Well, this runs, but it's not the
uh the environment that we want, right?
I can do this.
See if it does anything.
All right. So, this doesn't do much,
right?
Maybe I can figure out where this comes
from.
GPU utilization metric disabled.
The dashboard.
Uh, it shouldn't be, but it appears that
it is. Oh, you know what? Yes, it is.
It's this specific branch that I'm on.
Uh there's something weird with
launching that thing from multiple
processes. So I disabled it for then.
So yes,
Uh, what the hell?
Where?
So, this is going to go into
Yeah. I don't see where the hell these
are.
driving me nuts. Okay. Well, I It's like
for the third day in a row, it's like I
try, but I can't.
There's like only so much I can do. It's
not productive for me to just sit here
like trying to guess what the hell with
the repo.
Um,
so I have an hour and a half.
I mean, it truly drives me nuts, but
like what am I supposed to do? I'd
really like to help them.
And
right. So what I was going to do here
Okay. So breakout is a totally different
config, right?
it's actually it's a bigger network,
right?
It's a bigger network that can
definitely go faster.
It actually just gets slower with bloat
under defaults.
Okay, so we can't do photographs. We
need to fix this.
Trying to see if this is
You may want to look at it does
compilation correctly. Okay, hang on.
I figured it was just broken in that and
I was like, I can just update to the
PyTorch run. I think they just ported
it, right?
Are you sure? Cuz it's it's giving me
these errors inside of
it's giving me errors inside of the
optimizer, though.
I mean, this looks fine to me, right?
Follow the policy.
Uh yeah, this just like runs with Adam
so far.
Might not want to change the compile
mode.
Okay, let's say I take your word on
this.
Good morning.
4:30 p.m. here. Good morning.
Well, okay. Here we go. We're up to
240k.
We only have 256 MS.
So, this is going to be quite
The goal is going to be to have to
compile the entirety of train.
I wish it would give me a error message
that does not suck.
[Music]
Okay.
So, you can't compile this
I think this should be fine for
compilation, right?
Oh, I think it's being really stupid
right now.
I mean, this is basically like glorified
rag is the thing because like these
models are just so incredibly stupid.
It's like piecing together Google [ __ ]
honestly.
Wait,
hang on. Does this Am I dumb?
Row.
Not sure there's a problem. Well,
apparently here it's breaking on the
advantage calc and I didn't attempt to
do anything.
So presumably
presumably I'm missing something, right?
Of course. Um
the model just added completely stupid
[ __ ] to my code, so that doesn't help.
Huh? I This isn't even any different, is
it?
I confused it because I gave it the
wrong file. I'm dumb.
I don't know why I used the LM. I should
have just done this.
What am I currently working on? I am
trying to well I wrote some scripts that
basically say that we should be able to
make puffer lip way faster uh with
compilation but not in the way that I
was previously using compilation.
So that is going to be the objective is
is one part of a much larger thing for
puffer 4.
Let's say
I think we can make it much faster
actually.
Ah, because it has to return nothing,
right?
I see.
It's supposed to return void.
What if we only torture compile some of
the helpers?
Then it doesn't work cuz you need to
compile the loop. The loop is the thing
that needs to be like fixed
cuz the thing is the loop is so fast.
It needs to do the whole thing at once.
Uh custom PO so far for V4. Yes.
possibly some small algo changes, but
do you know what the difference in
overhead is? Because like
shouldn't it combine
the kernels for small models
or do you literally just have to write a
custom thing to get it to fuse.
I'm almost like literally if we just had
all the layer types in uh is like easily
accessible
relatively nice chunks of CUDA,
I'd honestly be very very happy just
doing all this stuff and cuz like the
amount of time you spend trying to debug
and use all these overbuilt shitty
profiling systems to get the code to
just not be unusably slow is just
pathetic
when you're rolling out the whole model.
Yeah,
it's like it's honestly so stupid that
we've decided to use like that
everything should just be shitty Python
and then we build shitty systems on top
of the shitty Python to like escape the
performance nightmares
and then we're still not at anywhere
near MFU.
Oh, okay. Cool. So, this actually did
something, right?
I you know it this might end up becoming
the Joseph just rewrites torch arc. I
don't know.
It's just so freaking sad like the state
of software
it up major. It doesn't let me set it at
the start of the damn stream. That's the
problem. if they could just default it.
If you have a way so I can default it,
that would be great. But otherwise, it
just clears it every time I start the
stream. And yes, if you start a stream
on Twitch, you set the category, but I
don't start the stream on Twitch. I
started on Reream, so it goes to all
three platforms. And the integrations
just suck.
PPO and one.cu,
the Perf gets wild. Yeah. The problem
though is if you do that, Lucas, like
nobody will use it.
Like literally nobody will use it.
And then you don't even have like you
don't even have the right algorithm at
that point
cuz if you just implement like vanilla
PO it'll it just
like that's not what you even want.
So basically what I think happened right
is like you do need the flexibility of
having some tools. You can't just see C
like one CU everything but like the
solution is not pietorch either. The
solution is like some collection of
nicely implemented reusable chunks of
like individual layers um you know
perhaps individual optimizer routines
and the like.
And as usual, we just went a couple
layers too high.
No default. Yep. Lovely.
Thanks, Twitch.
What's the TLDDR of today's progress? We
can make puffer way faster
and I'm working on how
for the ballpark. No idea. Potentially a
lot.
I do this.
Three large kernels.
I mean, that's like going to be a cool
and very impressive project.
That'll absolutely be a very impressive
project.
I mean, yeah, you could literally get
that to be 100x faster than puffer lib
on very small models, right?
What, like 100 million to billion step
per second training, some crazy thing
like that.
Is that actually like a reasonable net
as well? Wait, let me think how much
that could potentially be.
Can you actually get a 128 dim? Hang on,
let me think. Teraflops.
Is that like 128 hidden as well?
I think you can get that.
Gradient is the bottleneck. Yeah,
that's funny.
Okay. But like realistically, right, if
I can get this to if I can get high MFU
above,
let's say when you get to a million
parameters, I get good MFU and I have
like a reasonable decay down, then it's
like pretty good, right?
because it's like how much do I care
about
I definitely don't care about like super
optimizing nets under 100k params.
Oh, 32 hidden. Yeah. Like do I really
care about hyper optimizing nets under
100k per? Probably not. Um
do I care about nets like 100k to a few
million? Yeah. Like you can do useful
stuff with that, right?
Does it help me to get like without
crazy batching params, does it help me
to get 100 million instead of 5 million
steps per second on some of the tests?
Yeah, that actually does help a lot,
right?
Sort of how I think about stuff.
in 1 mil pram torch is fine. Well, it's
not fine by default.
You actually have to work very hard to
get it to be fine. Heck, I have it
better than anybody else has it. And
this is still way slow. Like, this could
still be way faster, right? We do RL at
millions of steps per second standard
like for research for clients. So it's
pretty good but like it could just be so
much better and just like everybody
asked me how on earth did you get it
that fast and I say how's it this slow
right?
Literally nobody understands what
hardware can do anymore. It's nuts.
Nobody understands at all.
Okay.
Adobot.
Um, hang on. That's like crap.
I'm going to have to do it on a I have
to do that on a separate browser, I'm
pretty sure.
But I'll add Moobot. Thanks.
20 ELO. Yeah.
Yes. I'm pretty sure it's like a
it's like an action formulation and
pruning thing.
Tiny models transfers to
100k params
when run the whole sweeps in seconds.
Speeds up research so much.
I mean honestly like
this is a lot of the stuff we're doing
now. Puffer our goal at the moment we're
going to have the largest scale like
analysis of reasonable experiments in
puffer 40
and you're going to be able to play with
all the data very easily.
But I have noticed right that a lot of
the you're really not getting a lot of
speed up when it pushes the model sizes
down and it pushes those prams down.
And we could definitely speed that up a
ton.
I guess one thing you could do, right,
is like I guess we could have some
standard network types where we have
them full CUDA or we could have some
standard network blocks being full CUDA.
Honestly, that would be really nice.
I just don't have anybody around that
like does that type of work
because we've had to hack like for
instance the core LSTM we use. We've had
to hack that thing so much.
It actually would probably be kind of
reasonable.
What are you doing for your nets though?
Are you doing like do you have your own
naive uh m naive matrix multiplications?
Are you like hooking into blast or do
you have some optimized thing? Like what
are you doing for the core
I wish I could persuade you to come like
come PR some of this stuff to Puffer.
You get quite a bit of reach with it if
you do.
We have a heck of a lot of people
hacking on RL with this. The cool thing
with Puffer, right, is like we've also
been able to do this for the M side and
it's really not that limited, right?
because you just write arbitrary C and
we get that to be fast enough
LSTM and CNN. Oh,
well, we do have implementations of
these. They're just crap, right? Like
here,
I mean, I did um
if you want references, these match the
PyTorch ones exactly.
Where is it?
Puffarel.
Ah, here we go. So, right here.
Inline assembly. H.
But are you just doing naive map moles
then or like ideally you want to do some
blocking, right?
Because we have right here. So, this is
like mini pietorrch, right? And it's
really naive just like silly looping. We
have the LSTM in here. We got layerm. We
got a bunch of stuff. Like I wouldn't
want to just port this directly to CUDA
because this is going to be way less
efficient than using um like nicely
blocked matal kernels.
That's like one of the main annoyances I
suppose that's preventing me from doing
this type of stuff more broadly is like
that stuff actually matters and that
stuff's really annoying to
Also, default PyTorch CNN's have been
really slow. Like really, really slow.
No puffer.
I don't mean depend on puffer right I
mean like if you write some extensions
because like you're going to limit it a
lot for instance if
I think the the Other thing that's going
to be tough, right, is Oh, yeah. Uh, at
those speeds, you really do need the
environment to be in CUDA, don't you?
That's tough.
Well, I guess Lucas, there is a project
I've been thinking about doing where I
think it wouldn't be that hard to get
CUDA compatible versions of a lot of the
puffer ms. You basically
like our stuff is just no memory Alex
minimal C anyways, right? You would
basically just copy it such that one env
is one CUDA thread.
You wouldn't paralyze it any more than
that, but that's kind of already enough,
right?
Well, you say it's not a big problem,
but we've got some pretty big ends,
right?
Buffer is only a few like a few thousand
lines for all our core training and
stuff and hyper pram sweeps. Uh we have
50,000 lines worth of environments.
Is that even like a smart thing though?
I'm trying to think.
I actually don't know enough about GPU
architecture to know like what speeds
you're going to expect out of your N per
core because actually you're
I might still be okay.
Mario M is 3K. Okay, 3K is neur is like
neural MMO is that long. So,
I'm a little suspicious of that. I
believe 1.5
But like that's going to really limit
what M's you can use, right?
Like how we how big is that cash even?
I have no idea off the top of my head
how big that is.
1.8 KB.
Wait, is it
So yeah, the end.
How the heck does that work? Wait, you
don't need the source there. You need
the memory for the N to sit in there,
don't you? And then you have a bunch of
copies of that.
Let me as few lines as possible. I mean,
without golfing yet. I kind of did,
right?
like my PhD it was over 10K
and then I just wrote it. Have you seen
the code for this?
Like this is one of our heavier
environments, right?
So this is I forget where it is. It's
like 3K.
But this is just brain dead top to
bottom. Like write the environment code
as simply as possible.
Obviously, you can cut a lot out of it
if you're like okay removing details of
the procedural generation and like
details of things we use for rendering,
right? Like to make it possible to do
nice rendering.
Um,
and then like there aspects like other
features that aren't really heavily
integrated but are kind of cool,
right? Like a full game.
I'm literally just like bicting
manually.
Trip it down. Well, I mean, there's
there's kind of limited value in that,
Lucas, because like I'm going the
opposite way ultimately, right? The goal
is to have neural MMO 4 be closer to a
full game that has all sorts of new
types of challenges that are really
going to test out RL algorithms and
elicit, you know, what we can really do.
It's not going to be towards like a
simpler, smaller environment. Obviously,
I have such a high emphasis on
simplicity that the goal is like maybe
neural MMO 4 is only four or 5,000 lines
and is several times cooler and has way
more stuff in it, right?
But it's not going to be neural MMO in a
thousand lines with a bunch of stuff
removed.
I don't know. We'll see when I do it. I
have so many things to do for this field
before I even think of stuff like that.
uh no we do not have our own binding of
Isaac man.
Oh we do not have all the things.
I this debugging [ __ ] is so obnoxious.
Um,
Uh, yes it technically is,
but I can make it better than it is now.
Wait, what is this thing?
Wait, I am. Oh, no. I'm not. There we
go.
Of course, the cool people building
stuff and posting nothing.
I really like these little plots as
well. This is fun.
right. You're golfing a little bit to
fit 200 though. I will say you're doing
the tiny grad thing and golfing a little
bit.
It would be better at 300.
It still looks super impressive though.
Yeah. So, something is just massively
screwy.
Oh, you know what? I wonder
does this modify ratio in place?
Tiny Grad's a really good project. They
the golfing thing is kind of dumb
though.
Thanks. How is the uh how's the drone
stuff going?
Interesting.
That is something though.
What envy you're running there?
Wait, hang on.
Wait, hang on. What are we seeing here?
You can always ungul it. Having all the
code on one screen really helps me.
If you really want that, just get a
vertical monitor, man.
Like having it that that compact is kind
of nuts.
Telemetry is good. Solid. What? M
breakout. But we're just we're trying to
mess around with compile
29 more for swarm simil.
Yeah, easy 40 grand worth of drones.
Not impossible, mind you, but it would
take um
it would have to at least be like some
reasonable
contract behind it
for that to happen.
That's too much for me to spot just for
the hell of it.
Uh, they sent the meta guys sent me back
some instructions
Well, the hope with the drones is that
eventually the drones get so good that
it's pointless to have soldiers. So, if
two countries want to fight, they just
blow up each other's drones until one of
them runs out of money. And then it's
like, okay, now we sue for peace.
Anything more is just a stupid war
atrocity.
So, I don't know.
weapons not always bad,
but you can also do lots of other fun
stuff with them, of course, right?
They're like also just they're really
good they're really good for just
studying multi- aent intelligence in
general. Just like having agile things
that fly around and coordinate is really
good for that in general.
economic war we're already doing. Yeah,
that is the ideal outcome I would say.
Right.
Multi-agent combat drone puffer ramp.
There have been like things that aren't
that far off of it.
I don't know. I'm not really opposed to
that type of stuff personally. I just
there's like stuff that I would think of
as cooler, you know?
I can think of all sorts of cooler stuff
than that.
What are your cooler ideas?
Material science, biological sim,
accelerating areas of science, heavily
dependent on sim.
Those are some really cool ones. like
actually understanding intelligence as
well in like a very efficient way.
That's not throwing
hundreds of billions of dollars at this
point at freaking bigger and bigger
language models that like
are not learning through interaction at
all
and like really don't tell us very much
about intelligence.
This is a bunch of math. Does this thing
actually work? Is this a thing that you
can implement that actually works
or is this like one of those 40,000 ft
in the air things that you can't
actually use?
is this is going to drive me nuts. Just
like
not be computed
how to model the world.
I do not like things that cannot be
computed.
Are the computable approximations any
good? Can we run an experiment and solve
puffer?
of all the things, right? Like
this is what I think. This is how I
think about these things.
So obnoxious. What the hell,
bro? Like why?
Okay. Is the provably best time agent.
The thing is your proof bounds suck,
right? So that doesn't help.
Like basically nothing in the
theoretical side of RL does anything.
Like you're improving on a bound that if
there even exists one is so low as to be
useless.
All right. Well,
these guys are like annoying the hell
out of me with this. Um, they've given
me like four different or no, five
different things at this point, and none
of them work. Um, so I cannot help them.
But anyways,
I am going to go get some dinner. Uh,
thanks for tuning in, folks. I probably
have some client work to do in the
evening.
I'll be back most likely 10:30 a.m.
tomorrow Eastern.
Uh, one moment.
For folks who've been tuning in,
welcome. I do high performance
reinforcement learning, research, dev,
tons of stuff. It's all open source.
It's all at puffer.ai if you want to
help me out for free. Start the repo.
Literally it. Join the Discord to get
involved and follow me on X for all the
content, including educational stuff if
you're new.
So, thanks and I will be uh back
tomorrow.
Bye.